cardinals have seven stolen bases
hit to the right side base hit tommy
edmond being waved in
the throw by polanco is cut off edmond
scores
easily and with that base hit it's one
nothing cardinals
goldie is able to stay on it and then
shoots that knuckle curve right through
that wide open right side
orinato the runner at first base
goldschmidt at second base
the 2-2 and the young sends a fly ball
out to deep left field
it's at the track oh god
three run homer paul de young
oh did he need that one four nothing
cardinals here in the first
and then gets himself that hanging curve
ball
just stays up enough and he puts a
charge into it now you are right dan he
needed that
they needed that put a little put a
little momentum early into this game
gonna be the eighth pitch of this at bat
coming up bases loaded nobody out
tom sends it to left tailing away from
o'neal
he makes the catch moran trying to score
and he will moran scores
and the pirates are on the board they're
playing them that way that's the only
thing
the only reason why this ball doesn't
drop and they score
a couple of runs joey cora being
aggressive knowing he's at the bottom of
the lineup
sending colin moran o'neal with a strong
throw it was accurate but an in-between
hop
tough one to handle for kissman
o'neal struck out first time up runners
at the corners
and that finds a hole base hit into left
goldschmidt will score to make it 5-1
and the cardinals will enjoy their
four-run lead back
tyler o'neal not wasting any time he
sees the big knuckle curve he sees the
hump in it
just up in the zone and shoots it right
there through the 5-6 hole
i like being aggressive in that spot you
got ducks on the pond
you get a strike go for it and the
infield was
in as well with the shift came in tied
for 10th
in the national league in rbis
on the ground and through evans will
score
reynolds will take his spot colin moran
with an rbi single
does it again now a career 300 hitter at
least with runners in scoring position
um anytime you have first and third
situation what they're holding runners
on and you throw a breaking ball
boy that's perfect pitch for a
left-handed batter to roll over
through that hole and colin moran
that's all he does just rolls it over
has a lot of room over there and
put in play
the run is in gregory polanco with the
run batted in
that's huge choked up stayed short and
they're fighting that
wow fastball off that was right in on
the hands at 96.
last year he strikes out on that i think
yeah i don't know if he can get to it
and uh
yeah just stay short you never know
and that was just that close just that
close
polanco two for two tonight that's a big
one yep that's a big one
adam frazier's gonna try it wow he got
him
what a play by adam frazier i
i mean how he made this throw he put so
much on this throw
not only does he get rid of it very
quickly but i didn't think he could get
that much on that throw from where he
was
and a good scoop by the red beard i mean
he threw that ball over 150 feet
and right there i mean i'm sorry he
doesn't practice that
he's not making that play in bp or or
any time
i mean
arenado with a drive into left sinking
and it gets by again tom
one run in two runs in auronado drives
in a pair
and he can thank tom again yeah tom has
just not
looked comfortable in this series out in
left field so far it's not like he's
he's just not trusting himself caught in
between on this one
that's three times in this series that
nolan aronado
has picked up a double with miss plays
he
i mean if you want to call him that with
tom in left field yeah i mean
if it's a tough play but i don't think
that tom got a great
beat on it anyhow and it looked like he
got there just sneaks under his glove
either way
nolan takes advantage of it in this spot
sees it down
and pick up a couple more if reynolds
walks you charge that to hicks
now batting right-handed
and over the head of o'neill
dumbfounded that's going to be so weird
it's got to be so weird you're up there
you're battling against the heart
throwing righty
and a 3-2 count you get turned around
right-handed got to get another helmet
who knows maybe even a different bat
facing a hard-throwing left-hander and
you turn them around
rebels have been one of the better
hitters in the league hitting lefties
all year
and his career 654 ops against lefties
801 against freddy's
out toward the gap vader shaded that way
can't get there backed up by o'neal but
reynolds comes in to score and colin
moran with his
third hit tonight and don't look now but
the tying runs coming up here in the
seventh
hard throwing lefty soft throwing lefty
look at that fastball 98 off the plate
in
i think colin thought it was going to be
an out off the bat
yeah bader i don't know if bader called
it early
or somehow the left fielder o'neal
didn't see it but o'neil really didn't
go for it
two sliders in a row front door there to
harrison bader i'm not
exactly sure that's what stratton was
trying to do but it was highly effective
broken bat and a run will score good
play to get peter
this is a great play right here by
phillip evans you know you got to move
harrison's trucking down the line stabs
it makes a strong throw nice play
williams with a drive out to left center
off the bench pinch hit two run
homer justin williams ball was smoked
yeah it was matt carpenter's not the
only
lefty off the bench that could do some
damage justin williams said give me a
shot
and the pirates down to their final
strike the o2
rounded up the middle tommy edmond is
there and the cardinals have taken their
first two games in pittsburgh the final
tonight 12-5 and they'll look for a
sweep
tomorrow